greetings my friends and welcome to a
dummy Christmas review it's time we take
a look at National Lampoon's Christmas
vacation say remember when John Hughes
was funny
so does this movie this film centers
around a family man played by Chevy
Chase hey remember when Chevy Chase was
funny
so does this movie who has a charming
family of a wife who's only known for
these films that Juliette Lewis chick
who we never see anymore and that Big
Bang Theory tool it appears that after
having years of bad vacations they have
finally decided to have one vacation
there at home I had a vacation at my
home once it's not easy renovating a can
of coffee so they invite over all the
people who auditioned for Everybody
Loves Raymond even one who actually got
out and they tried to have a Merry
Christmas with absolutely no communities
which for many critics at the time is
exactly what happened but the glue of
the movie seems to beat Chevy Chase he
plays your everyday likeable man who's
constantly trying to cheat on his wife
and Beverly D'Angelo plays the everyday
wife who hasn't divorced him for some
reason we also have Randy Quaid whose
smell actually penetrates the movie
screen and of course his family the
mother from Tasmania the standby for
punch Lee Adams and nude sister because
here see that's good sister go IMDB it
they're like identical I keep forgetting
which ones waiting for Santa Claus and
which ones waiting for the belly busting
monsters through high jinks hilarity in
all sorts of funniness National
Lampoon's Christmas vacation shows were
the real value in a family Christmas
vacation lies with a terrible
who's mean to his family and always
wishes to get away from them even though
he constantly brings them closer I know
that doesn't make any sense
but in a way dissing Christmas make no
sense either this is Chitra even saying
don't go away Christmas I want to stay
in this room